في قلب السعوديه الرياض الى اهالي المملكه
في اليوم وبالتحديد الى جبل اللوز حيث وصل
الزائر الابيض
كما وعدناكم مع هاني الصياد
[موسيقى]
من جبل اللوز في اليوم ينضم الينا جميل
ولكن انا قاعد اقول لك وانصحك انك تسكني
في نيوم خاصه
حاليا او من خلال منظر الزائر الابيض
اليوم اللي
كده في ساعات الليل من يوم امس وتوقعات
ايضا باستمرار حاله تساقط الثلوج حتى مساء
هذا اليوم طبعا العدد الزوار صراحه لحد
الان ما زال في في قدوم همم يمكن احدهم في
الجهه الاخرى وايضا لاحظ الجهه الاخرى من
الثلوج في همم على باقي قمم تساقط همم
الثلوج في همم هذه الجبال وكذلك ايضا
التحذيرات ما زالت متواصله من قبل سواء
الجهه الامنيه او ايضا الامن البيئي اللي
يقوم بحمايه هذه المنطقه من اجل تضاريسها
ومناظرها الطبيعيه الخلابه طبعا لان لا
يمكن كميه الثلوج اللي هذه الموجه على
تحديدا
لتساقطت او تساقط الثلوج منذ ليله امس حتى
اليوم يمكن كميه قليله لكن لسه التوقعات
ما زالت مستمره وايضا التوقعات في ازدياد
ال ال الحاله او تقلبات الجويه لتساقط
الثلوج او كذلك الحاله الضبابيه مستمره
والتحذيرات زي ما ذكرت انه ما زالت مستمره
من قبل مركز الارصاد اللي ما زال يقوم
بتحضيرات عبر الرسائل الاسم اس او كذلك
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي او ايضا عبر
الايميلات اللي يقوم بارسالها للمواطنين
والمقيمين في هذه المنطقه او كذلك المناطق
القريبه من نيوم واللي ايضا يتوجهون برده
عندما داخل المطارات لن ينسى خاصه في مطار
نيوم حيث عدد السياح اللي وصلوا في
الاسبوع الماضي
بالوصول الى هذه المنطقه يقولون بعض
الارشادات ويعطونهم بعض النصائح ويعطونهم
ايضا بعض التعليمات عند صعودهن الى هذه
القمه طبعا لا ننسا هناك برده خد تقدمها
همم منطقه نيوم في ظل هذا تساقط الثلوج من
خلال الخدمات العامه اللي يحتاجها الزوار
او السياح الى هذه المنطقه وايضا هناك
برضه اجراءات امنيه يعني وحمايه امنيه عند
الصعود الى هذه القمه خاصه من مخاطر
الانزلاق اللي دائما ما تكون على طبقه
الازفلتيه عند الصعود الى هذه القمه هذا
هو اللوز وهذا هو الثلج
[موسيقى]